all right charmaine
yeah charmaine where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
ginzora pennsylvania
and tell me about your family you had
mom and dad when you were a kid
[Music]
my parents were both uh
drug addicts um
[Music]
my dad was everything my mom was
beautiful
she had like lots of boyfriends and me
and my brother
rarely seen her dad
but um
they're both uh
dead now because of their drug habits
they overdose and pass away how would
you describe your childhood in general
i don't know
it wasn't all bad
you know
i have really good
memories with my family even though it
was like really
crazy
they're so great
i grew up in the woods they're nice
yeah
way different what kind of kid were you
in high school
what's that what kind of kid were you in
high school
kind of like
i don't know i was really smart but i
didn't go to school
how far did you go to school 11th grade
[Music]
would you do that
i had my son
and then
i mean i was in
rehabs in
hospitals since i've been 13.
but uh
after i left high school i went to
florida
the drug use has been a constant for you
since 13
how did you first get introduced to
drugs
my dad
my dad
maybe my grandmother but
it wasn't so bad i think i like had a
percocet when i was in like fifth grade
but heroin
i was 13.
my dad um
i don't know he was it was his way to
fix my pain you know
there's no abuse in your childhood
there's no what no abuse in your
childhood
uh not by my family my the
i don't know this is weird because
you're gonna
people are gonna hear this but whatever
um my dad his uh
he owes like his drug dealers money and
stuff and that was kind of my abuse i
guess
what happened there
i don't know i guess i was how he paid
them off
how old were you
13.
how old are you now
33 33. you have kids i do
where are the kids
they're back home um
with my brother actually
my daughter's with her dad
and you've been staying in kensington
for how long
five years
i got out of here for a little while for
about
a year and i got clean
and um i was doing really well
but i guess like my legal issues push me
back out all the time
it's like
they just hold you in you can't get out
what are your legal issues um
like i just
it all is like drug related you know
my habit but what is your drug today
fentanyl
yeah
fentanyl is very popular here in
kensington yeah but the crazy thing is
it's not even fentanyl anymore it's like
tranquilizer and
all kinds of like synthetic stuff it's
it's not even real drugs
how do you make money now
um
[Music]
i do dates like that's what i think most
of the girls do yeah
um
i mean it sucks but i've been doing it
for a long time not like out here out
here so different
but when i went to florida i i escorted
for a while and danced and stuff like
that
and i think i've just been like
programmed since i've been young to like
just be numb to it
you think that what happened to you at
13 may have kind of set you on that path
probably or maybe kind of normalized it
in some way i think it normalized
yeah i have like a built-in forgetter
i'm really good at like
forgetting things
that's helpful sometimes
yeah
yeah but then time slips by you know
what's the hardest part of living here
in kensington
um
i just miss real people like um
the hardest part of living here is that
like
you just can't find real people like
friends or do you have any friends at
all yeah
i think so but probably not just street
acquaintances
yeah
i think you know if i'm not out next to
them i wake up broke
i'd like to think that some of them are
my friends the coolest people are down
here the most interesting and talented
and beautiful people
but they're just
stuck
you still talk with your kids
i haven't no
is that difficult for you
yeah
yeah but what would i tell them yeah so
there's the shame and the drug use helps
not feel the shame
yeah
yeah
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
hell yeah
it's unnecessary
i feel like i put myself through hell
and like
i make things so much harder than they
have to be
but i keep myself constantly busy so i
don't have to think you know
[Music]
what's been the lowest point of your
life
or is this it
yeah this is probably
there's been some highs and lows
but this is like um
it's probably like a
my most aware time
like awareness
and that makes everything harder you
know where do you stay at night where do
you
sleep
around
anywhere
most of the time i don't i don't sleep i
try not to sleep
i catch a nod here and there and um
when i do finally go to sleep it's like
dangerous
because you're going for a long time
yeah
yeah and i don't know like you couldn't
wake me if you tried
are you lonely yeah
yeah but you can be lonely in a crowd of
people out here
you got to be tough out here on the
streets right
mm-hmm
yeah
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
i don't know
i feel like i don't have
healthy fears
but um
like maybe i should but um
my biggest fear is like
losing any more time like it just it
keeps disappearing on me i've lost
everybody that i love
and um i always thought i'd have time to
see them again
are you afraid you might be here the
rest of your life
yeah sometimes i think about it
or maybe following your parents
footsteps
i already have yeah no but they both
died young
yeah my mom was 47 last year
she passed away
all by herself
from a fentanyl xanax overdose
and um my dad was 51.
they were young
yeah
what emotions do you go through
you get depressed or anxious or
angry
no i just turn all that off
i think if i catch an emotion it would
be like
this
sad
if you could live your life all over
again what would you have done
differently
i don't know
i'd like to say i wouldn't have done
anything differently because
like
struggle makes you who you are
and i know if i just get through this
[ __ ] like
i just wouldn't have left home you know
and that's probably all
how do you think living this life has
changed you living this street and drug
life
it hasn't
and that's a shitty thing
because i get hurt every day because i
like
i just stay the same and people take
advantage of that you think you're too
kind-hearted for this
yeah
it's so it's a weakness you know out
here your kindness is a weakness
you still have hope of getting your life
together um you do
yeah i don't know how i'm going to
though
i i have no idea how and it's not
because i haven't been to 50 rehabs
i have been i know what i have to do
it's like getting past a certain point i
just i don't know
you have to be ready to do it
yeah
what was your favorite experience
as a child or in your life
favorite memory
i don't know
my favorite memories are with my
children
as a kid
i just had memories with my mom and um
like her best friend we used to all live
together
it was fun
camping and [ __ ] with my family
so working as a prostitute here in
kensington
your clients are mostly
people that just come here for some fun
yeah
yeah that's what you want to call it
i know it may not be fun for you
oh i mean
it can be i guess
what do you think of your of your
clientele
they're okay
yeah
yeah i mean there's some scumbags out
here you know
but
you just try to keep it to like regular
people you know that you see all the
time yeah you have regulars yeah that
helps
it's a little safer right yeah because
like it's really dangerous
have you had things like that happen to
you yeah
what have you been through
i mean i've been
i mean all of us have been like raped
out here of us girls at least once or
twice
some even more though but then there's
girls disappearing
and there's a lot of girls disappearing
and a few have been killed like just
recently too
that i know and cared about
and
[Music]
i've had a gun point in my face too many
times to count at this point
for what purpose to rob you
or to like take advantage of me and not
have to
i mean there it's just
it's different out here it's not like
florida you know
you have pimps out here
yeah they do
i don't have a pet
and i don't
want to ever have a pimp but i have had
situations with them
and your clients sometimes
want to do risky things or strange
things
like you ever do without a condom no
no i don't
i have yeah but out here isn't it's
really bad like
a lot of people have like
like people i know like young people
i have like hiv
see
all that stuff
and like it scares me i found out one of
my friends had it and got real scared
but there's like you can be homeless in
kensington like they give out a lot of
food and
testing and help you know so
would you describe yourself as
happy sometimes
are there days when you're actually in a
good mood yeah
as they might might not be
real but
i try to
i don't want to like lose myself you
know
feel like if you become the same color
as the street you're lost you know
i can't get lost
are there benefits to this lifestyle
are there things you like about it
no
the only benefits could
be getting through it you know
if you make it through it
you're a survivor right yeah i
definitely am a survivor
you notice at some point you start doing
things that are just a little bit
you keep pushing the limits of what
what's okay yeah and giving up more and
more
absolutely
yeah
it's easy to do out here it all gets
normalized
everything's normal
you know
you have no idea
you've been coming to kensington for how
long
five years five years has it gotten
worse or better
it's gotten much worse yeah yeah
there used to be like
i don't know there just used to be rules
to it like there just isn't any more
and even the fentanyl
which originally was just something that
they put in the heroin
even even the fentanyl now has something
they're putting in it right
tell
is the worst
just go to sleep i don't know what else
to say about it
people
i don't know what to say about training
there's nothing you can say about
drinking
it's ridiculous i don't know people are
dying from the withdrawal and i guess
there's not even much you can do
to get off of it
you sometimes feel helpless against your
addiction
what do you wish people understood
about this lifestyle
what do you think most people don't
understand about it
that like
there's people out here worth saving
there's still like people alive out here
yeah
what's your biggest regret
not being mom to my children yeah
it's not surprising
charmaine what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
that time never stops
and not to take it for granted
what would you say to your kids if if
they saw this
i pray to god they don't see this
but i love them
this was something that was out of your
control
wasn't a decision you made
i made many decisions
it was
it's my decision to be here
i don't blame anybody but myself
do you punish yourself a lot for
being in the situation
i don't know i guess that's what you
could call it maybe
just get high and forget about it
all right charmaine thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out here
yeah
thank you
you